Simulation is an important
tool in the analysis
of probabilistic phenomena.
For example, suppose
that X, Y, and Z
are independent
random variables,
and you're interested in
the statistical properties
of this random variable.
Perhaps you can find
the distribution
of this random variable by
solving a derived distribution
problem, but sometimes
this is impossible.
And in such cases,
what you do is,
you generate random samples
of these random variables
drawn according to
their distributions,
and then evaluate the function
g on that random sample.
And this gives you one sample
value of this function.
And you can repeat
that several times
to obtain some kind of
histogram and from that,
get some understanding about
the statistical properties
of this function.
So the question is, how can
we generate a random sample
of a random variable whose
distribution is known?
So what we want is to
create some kind of box
that outputs numbers.
And these numbers
are random variables
that are distributed according
to a CDF that's given to us.
How can we do it?
Well, computers typically
have a random number generator
in them.
And random number generators,
typically what they do
is generate values
that are drawn
from a uniform distribution.
So this gives us
a starting point.
We can generate uniform
random variables.
But what we want is to generate
values of a random variable
according to some
other distribution.
How are we going to do it?
What we want to do is to create
some kind of box or function
that takes this uniform random
variable and generates g of U.
And we want to find the
right function to use.
Find a g so that the
random variable, g of U,
is distributed according to
the distribution that we want.
That is, we want
the CDF of g of U
to be the CDF
that's given to us.
So let's see how we can do this.
Let us look at the discrete
case first, which is easier.
And let us look at an example.
So suppose that I want
to generate samples
of a discrete random variable
that has the following PMF.
It takes this value
with probability 2/6,
this value with probability
3/6, and this value
with probability 1/6.
What I have is a
uniform random variable
that's drawn from a
uniform distribution.
What can I do?
I can do the following.
Let this number here be 2/6.
If my uniform random
variable falls
in this range, which happens
with probability 2/6,
I'm going to report
this value for
my discrete random variable.
Then I take an
interval of length 3/6,
which takes me to 5/6.
And if my uniform random
variable falls in this range,
then I'm going to
report that value
for my discrete random variable.
And finally, with
probability 1/6,
my uniform random variable
happens to fall in here.
And then I report that [value].
So clearly, the value
that I'm reporting
has the correct probabilities.
I'm going to report this
value with probability 2/6,
I'm going to report that
value with probability 3/6,
and so on.
So this is how we can
generate random samples
of a discrete
distribution, starting
from a uniform random variable.
Let us now look at what we did
in a somewhat different way.
This is the x-axis.
And let me plot the CDF of
my discrete random variable.
So the CDF has a jump of 2/6, at
a point which is equal to that.
Then it has another
jump of size 3/6, which
takes us to 5/6 at
some other point.
And that point here corresponds
to the location of that value.
And finally, it has
another jump of 1/6
that takes us to 1,
at another point, that
corresponds to the third value.
And look now at this
interval here from 0 to 1.
And let us think as follows.
We have a uniform
random variable
distributed between 0 to 1.
If my uniform random
variable happens
to fall in this interval, I'm
going to report that value.
If my uniform random
variable happens
to fall in this interval, I'm
going to report that value.
And finally, if my uniform
falls in this interval,
I'm going to report that value.
We're doing exactly the
same thing as before.
With probability 2/6,
my uniform falls here.
And we report this
value and so on.
So what's a graphical
way of understanding
of what we're doing?
We're taking the CDF.
We generate a value
of the uniform.
And then we move
until we hit the CDF
and report the
corresponding value of x.
It turns out that
this recipe will also
work in the continuous case.
Let's see how this is done.
So let's assume that
we have a CDF, which
is strictly monotonic.
So the picture
would be as follows.
It's a CDF.
CDFs are monotonic,
but here, we assume
that it is strictly monotonic.
And we also assume
that it is continuous.
It doesn't have any jumps.
So this CDF starts at 0 and
rises, asymptotically, to 1.
What was the recipe that
we were just discussing?
We generate a value for a
uniform random variable.
We move until we hit the CDF,
and then report this value here
for x.
So what is it that we're doing?
We're going from u's to x's.
So we're using the
inverse function.
The cumulative takes
as an input an x,
a value on this axis, and then
reports, a value on that axis.
The inverse function
is the function
that goes the opposite way.
We start from a value
on the vertical axis
and takes us to the
horizontal axis.
Now, the important thing is
that because of our assumption
that f is continuous
and strictly monotonic,
this inverse function
is well-defined.
Given any point
here, we can always
find one and only
one corresponding x.
Now, what are the
properties of this method
that we have been using?
If I take some number c and then
take the corresponding number
up here, which is
going to be F_X of c,
then we have the
following property.
My random variable
X is going to be
less than or equal
to c if and only
if my random variable X
falls into this interval.
But that's equivalent to
saying that the uniform random
variable fell in that interval.
Values of the uniform
in this interval-- these
are the values that
give me x's that are
less than or equal to c.
So the event that X is
less than or equal to c
is identical to the
event that U is less than
or equal to F_X of c.
So this is how I am generating
my x's based on u's.
We now need to verify that
the x's that I'm generating
this way have the correct
property, have the correct CDF.
So let's check it out.
The probability that X is
less than or equal to c, this
is the probability that U is
less than or equal to F_X of c.
But U is a uniform
random variable.
The probability of being
less than something
is just that something.
So we have verified that
with this way of constructing
samples of X based
on samples of U,
the random variable that
we get has the desired CDF.
Let's look at an example now.
Suppose that we want
to generate samples
of a random variable, which is
an exponential random variable,
with parameter 1.
In this case, we
know what the CDF is.
The CDF of an exponential with
parameter 1 is given by this
formula, for non-negative x's.
Now, let us find the
inverse function.
If a u corresponds to 1
minus e to the minus x--
so we started with some x here
and we find the corresponding
u-- this is the formula that
takes us from x's to u's.
Let's find the formula that
takes us from u's to x's.
So we need to solve
this equation.
Let's send u to the
other side, and let's
send this term to
the left hand side.
We obtain e to the minus
x equals 1 minus u.
Let us take logarithms: minus
x equals to the logarithm
of 1 minus u.
And finally, x is equal to minus
the logarithm of 1 minus u.
So this is the inverse function.
And now, what we have
discussed leads us
to the following procedure.
I generate a random
variable, U, according
to the uniform distribution.
Then I form the
random variable X
by taking the negative of
the logarithm of 1 minus U.
And this gives me
a random variable,
which has an exponential
distribution.
And so we have found
a way of simulating
exponential random variables,
starting with a random number
generator that produces
uniform random variables.